venue
it's very odd this is a virtual teams
meeting
the purpose of this hearing today is to
consider an application
for a combined acne carriage and private
hire
vehicle drivers license which has been
submitted by
ian webb as it's a
team's meeting in their new technology
there's just a little bit of narrative
that i need to give everybody
the meeting is going to be broadcast
live to youtube
and will be capable of repeated viewing
so the entirety of the meeting will be
filmed except
for confidential or exempt items
if you've attended the meeting in person
and or if you make any
submissions and representations you will
be deemed to have consented to being
filmed
and that the images and sound recordings
could be used
for webcasting or training purposes
and what i say is that the council
members members of the public and the
press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
now because this is a virtual meeting i
do apologize to those of us who are
used to these things but i'm just going
to give a few pointers so far as
if i can put it virtual meeting and
etiquette
firstly can you please ensure that
microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
secondly that you do not interrupt other
speakers
thirdly that if you are attending the
meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
i i hope that won't arise and
finally you will be invited to speak and
ask questions
by the chair and if please be patient
and please
await your turn thank you for that brief
welcome and the reason why we're here
the next item on the agenda is the
election of the chairman for the hearing
so i pass that through to the floor
please i propose counsellor newman
yes yes that's that's second second
second it
johnny good thank you
right right um welcome everybody to this
virtual meeting of the regulatory
subcommittee um is there any apologies
for absence
and receive chair um declarations of
interest
newman the chairman of the committee sue
would you like to introduce yourself
thank you chairman i'm councillor sue
carpendale vice chairman of the
committee
john would you like to introduce
yourself please councillor john run
labor district council right and i'd
like to introduce the officers
in attendance uh the legal advisor david
good morning my name is david smith i'm
a solicitor
part of the shared legal team for west
central council and as the chairman
newman says i will be the legal advisor
during the course of this hearing
catherine um i'm a licensing
officer who would um doing the report
today
and i do also have in attendance with my
colleague my colleague
k sanders and for training purposes my
assistant manager emma richbelt
and my colleague vanessa oliver are
sitting in on the hearing as well
right okay
good morning chairman k sanders
licensing officer baby supper
and karen good morning everyone karen
sayer governance officer
very good um would the applicant like to
introduce himself
here
you're on mute mr webb
hi my name is ben webb
johnny good do you have any
representatives you want to introduce
um i have my nephew beside me because
um i'm not very good at technology
and he's just helping me go through the
yeah my name's john webb i'm a manager
of
jt travel um ian is my uncle
and if you're working for me should he
be great with his license
okay thank you john all right johnny
good
has that been have uh questions to the
licensed officer have there been any
requests from the parties for permission
to call witness
um no chair but my understanding is john
may be asked to speak
occasionally on behalf of mr ian webb
okay
right have the parties indicate that
they wish to present
documentation or material
no chat okay well we'll
move to the hearing and uh move over to
the
license officer please oh sorry i've got
to do exclusion of the press
and public sorry but on the basis
that the subcommittee considers that the
public
interest in excluding the public
outweighs the public interest
in its deliberations being held in the
public
it is resolved that under section
100 a stroke 4 of the local government
act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting
for item 6 on the grounds at the
it involves the likely disclosure of
exempt information
as defined in part one of schedule 12
of the act so i have a second for this
please
a counselor rational mute sorry
seconded
johnny good do you all agree the
committee john
do you agree okay yes
yeah um that's carrie all right very
good
we just need to wait for rob to advise
us when the live stream has ended before
we carry on
you